cheers Baxter how could a when that
start off this bila how else could I
possibly start off this V like Walker I
said I think you should have done that
no it's not the same he tried doing that
during this up as I say it doesn't have
the mantric that does oh okay so this
this almost seem like like episode one
the stuff like you know I could see this
coming out like right after the first
episode in terms of the story and the
jokes and stuff like that I mean this
was just so goofy and so random but it's
like it was just so funny and upbeat and
there's there's this horse that goes
around on a ball whoo cheers people up
and of course his name is Baxter and he
just keeps saying Jews back sorry I keep
saying it over and over and cheers up
BMO who is sad because her pregnant egg
which her acting break it is Alerian was
just taped a cup with an A in it oh and
that made her feel better and vintage a
curly oh we've got these more like James
Baxter you know you makes everybody feel
better be more like who I you know it's
so funny cuz I'm watching this late I'm
obvious again you're late to the game so
I'm sure a lot of people watching it's
like oh god that thing is back it's like
after you show someone the room and
everybody starts going oh hi it's like
you can't help it after seeing it though
you just want to say it oh so Finn and
Jake want to go and they want to make
they want find their own variation but
your hooves Baxter so so they try to
find their own version and and they try
to work out like the perfect sound and
the perfect motion everything and
finally they think they got it and they
worked hours and hours trying to get
this the sound right and the action they
finally God they turned Jake into a
whore and make Gazoo
ooh and they they're on Jake is amol and
that seems to make people happy
except for this dead person in a coffin
this ghost who comes out and starts
beating the crap out of them
oh he sprays milk out of him yes that's
right because wasn't there like the one
other ghost the one that they disconnect
somehow I kind of remember this that the
two girls that were like romantically
evolved or whatever what we weren't
wasn't somehow like they had milk blood
or something or what was it I don't
remember
come on like ghost princess or whatever
well I was just I'm just surprised out
of all the bizarre things are all the
normal things that happened one of the
most bizarre the guy's spitting out milk
everywhere but wasn't it something like
a baby I'm just making this up but
wasn't there something from like the
ghost princess episode we're like milk
and something to do with something or no
I don't remember I don't remember either
oh well okay if a viewer I could have
completely made that up I don't know but
it makes sense if go Sam milk blood
anyway or whatever he's spewing out or
crying out oh so there so this ghost is
about to beat the crap out of him Jake
gives the clapping signals of find him
in the world of the dead and the
Beckster comes in and it makes the guy
happy everybody's happy it bet he takes
his ball what son is the Hat it just
rides off and it's there right man just
made me feel good it's just a good
feeling episode I don't know why there
is something about just him riding
around bags dirt makes me laugh so yeah
I think it's fine I literally just an
editorial this is gonna be like a few
weeks after but I just a Natori oh cool
why do people love stupid and it's like
why do we like things kind of like
you know where we'll just laugh at
something it's like it makes no sense as
nonsensical but it's just you know so
funny and there is talent too that is
difficult and I think there is something
about pets I thought that just makes me
laugh and you were telling me before
this be log that James Baxter is
actually a very famous animator a Disney
animator and not only did he supplied
the voice for this but he did the
animation for James Baxter and sure
enough whale watching uh sounds like I
love the animation on that thing it is
so flowing and I think that's part of
what made it so funny is that even
though it's still very simple line
drawing
it's you know every frame is animated
and it's not like you know they froze
one and just move the arm or they move
like the legs in the head but then this
part keeps to us it's fully animated and
it looks different from anything else in
the show and removes dipper I should say
anything else in the show and that just
makes it so much funnier what he does is
you know he's saying and everything um
so I thought was great and now I want to
know more about James Baxter it's just
it it just makes you feel good it's just
a feel-good episode you know I don't
know if I can agree with it it's a
feel-good episode I think is I love you
I need BMO's in the bathtub who's gonna
scrap me I I did like where they were
trying to figure out how to make this
sound better they go to this one place
and they're like yeah just follow the
beat of your heart and it feels like and
he's literally walking blind on the go
and there's all the stuff in Jake gets
all excited over distortion pedals and
stuff because that would be me I can't
play guitar at all but I love the idea
of distortion pedals and stuff so and
then there's one point where Jake says
this is gonna change the world and
Finn's like I think you're over hyping
it and I think I don't know if it was
intentional or not or anything like that
I think they were almost made
a nod or a knock against themselves or
to other people that sit there and go oh
what I'm creating is going to make you
know change the world in its entirety
like there's a lot of episodes like the
Simon and Marcy episode or the
holly-jolly secrets where people watch
it they're like oh my god this is like
the groundbreaking episode this is the
one that everyone's gonna be affected by
but not everyone is and I think Finn is
like it's almost I thought I had turned
up I think it was more or less it could
be like this tiny little thing where
it's like people need to stop
overselling what they're talking about
or what they're doing it's like you may
love it you may think it's the best
thing in the world but it's probably not
going to change the world I think a lot
of things that do change the world the
intention is to not change the world you
know I don't know that's just me though
it's um I have come across like one or
two people that do like I think
everybody has that over sell something
either they're doing or someone else is
doing it's just like and they just know
they're gonna get picked up and they
know something Incredibles gang it's
like no no there's there's no way
there's no possible way this can't
become huge there's no and that's always
the hardest thing cuz it's like if it
does great but you're leaving yourself
no option for if it doesn't and that's
just gonna make the letdown all the more
painful it's like why put yourself
through that pain um so yeah okay with
you just like don't go for high kids but
no this one just seemed to have like a
lot of the he were just this sort of
random fun humor like when they're
trying to cheer BMO up and they just sit
here how about this and Jake's just take
Jake just take somebody it's that
wonderful random immaturity that's also
just it just seems really upbeat and
goofy and fun I'm the little girl where
they run up after inches like I wasn't
the ally and she's screaming in terror
and there's still like
I'm using sacred time let me come up to
where they have the shadows going right
that's like no no it's okay we just
thought up lines like why do they do
this that was great
so yeah it's just I mean it's a lot of
randomness but it just I don't even kind
of like the colors in it just seems sort
of more bright and colorful than usual
uh just something about I can't explain
it's just it's just the whole thing
around like James Baxter and now he's
just so upbeat and mellow and happy and
random it's like that's just the whole
episodes a whole episode man its life
it's the world James Baxter but that you
can't read that one that that says then
I don't even what I